Across the infinite cosmos of the video game
‘No Man’s Sky,’ there are a similarly
infinite number of alien lifeforms.
Through the use of procedural generation,
the game contains more than 18 quintillion
planets to discover — many of which teem
with extraordinary creatures.
While No Man’s Sky had a rocky reception
at launch, the developers have done persistent
work making this virtual universe worth exploring.
So, for this entry into the archive, we’ll
embark on a classic documentary-style expedition,
exploring the lives of extraterrestrials on
scorching worlds, frozen wastelands, and many
others.
I’ll also speculate on how the biology of
each lifeform might feasibly work.
I admit that there are a few too many total
planets for this Archivist to document, so
this documentary will focus on only the most
interesting ones I’ve discovered.
Now, let’s set off into the unknown, and
see what awaits us among the stars…
We’ll begin with an earth-like, temperate
world located a comfortable distance from
its host star.
Since we are the first explorers to ever witness
this planet, it’s up to us to come up with
a name.
We’ll call this ringed jewel of the cosmos
Planet Rhea — a land abundant with the promise
of discovery.
Entering the atmosphere near the equator,
we can see a vast landscape of green fields
stretching before us.
Under the orbiting rings above, who knows
what extraterrestrial life has emerged?
Stepping out of the spacecraft, I spot something
moving in the distance.
A herd of herbivorous giants are grazing on
the local vegetation.
These newly-discovered creatures also need
a name.
We’ll call them…
Titanomagnus Magnificus.
Which might be a bit much, but I’m excited.
The Titanomagnus seem to have converged upon
a niche similar to sauropod dinosaurs from
Earth’s past.
They survive by being too large for most predators
to bother with, and sustain their bulk by
vacuuming up over one ton of plant matter
each day.
With their long necks and curious ears, the
Titanomagnus actually resemble another earth
animal: the giraffe, a lifeform whose long
neck helps them reach leaves at the tops of
trees.
Yet there are no trees in this region of Planet
Rhea, so why bother with such a long neck?
Perhaps a tree-like genus recently went extinct…
or perhaps the necks serve as watchtowers
to keep an eye out for potential dangers.
And speaking of potential dangers.
A huge, armored predator is on the move.
I’ll call these unfriendly customers the
Arachnomantis, because, well, I can.
The Arachnomantis possess a bone crushing
beak, and seem to have some kind of exoskeleton.
The biological differences between the Arachnomantis
and Titanomagnus seem so extreme, I wonder
if — like land vertebrates and insects here
on Earth — these two terrestrial lineages
split long before crawling onto land.
Yet unlike insects, the Arachnomantis are
megafauna in their own right, and a serious
danger upon these plains.
With our different evolutionary origins, it’s
likely I wouldn’t be very tasty to an Arachnomantis…
but it’s best not to test that theory.
For the next leg of our voyage across Planet
Rhea, we’ll be traveling in a terrestrial
exocraft called a Roamer.
This vehicle will offer protection as we continue
to explore this unfamiliar land.
Plus, it’s nice to not have to walk for
the entire voyage.
Not far from our Roamer, something is disturbing
the grass.
This is a Crested Rhealope.
These diminutive grazers are difficult to
get a glimpse of, as they’ve learned their
best chance of survival in this world of giants
is to stay out of sight.
Their skittish behavior likens them to the
antelopes of the grasslands here on Earth.
We’re lucky to be able to get a sighting
of such a shy creature.
But Rhealope aren’t the only things hiding
in the grass.
Even more elusive are the shadowy Stripped
Dreadtooth.
These cat-like hunters are exceedingly difficult
to spot.
Like tigers, their unique pattern of stripes
help them blend into their environment, and
the spines on their back help them disappear
even further.
And this Dreadtooth has caught the scent of
something.
Typically, Dreadtooth feed only on Rhealopes,
and the youngest of Titanomagnus.
But this Dreadtooth has its sights on an adult.
We might have a serious fight on our hands.
The Dreadtooth circles in close…
then seems to think better of it.
A full grown Titanomagnus isn’t exactly
an easy target.
It’s just not worth the risk.
So, the Dreadtooth returns to the prowl, looking
for something a little smaller to snack on...
The sun is now setting on Planet Rhea.
Yet with the night, comes a final surprise.
The Arachnomantis, while a fearsome predator
during the daylight, lights up the dark with
a bioluminescent display as it calls out to
others of its kind.
This ritual, which might be for mating purposes,
is a touching one for such a deadly creature.
We’ve seen much during our travels across
planet Rhea, but now, the stars call us once
again.
This world is just one of many, and the moment
has come to continue our expedition…
The next stop on our voyage, planet Boreas,
lies on the outer edge of its star’s habitable
zone.
Entering the atmosphere, I find a land trapped
in a never-ending winter.
Boreas’s position, combined with a dim host
star, means temperature on the surface rarely
rises above freezing, and a layer of snow
and ice covers the surface year-round.
It’s not the sort of place one might expect
to find life…
Yet life is here all the same.
This is a Snowsnuffler, a lifeform perfectly
adapted for a sub-zero lifestyle.
Large, lumbering herbivores, they’re protected
from the cold thanks to a thick layer of fat
and insulating fur.
Wrapping oneself in the biological equivalent
of a thick winter coat is one of the most
common ways that animals here on Earth have
been able to conquer cold environments.
So, it makes sense the Snowsnufflers would
have a convergent tactic for staying warm.
But surviving the elements is only half the
battle.
To persist on planet Boreas, the Snowsnufflers
must also find food.
Luckily, this is something the Snowsnuffler
is quite good at.
Their sensitive trunks are equipped with scent
receptors powerful enough to locate the subterranean
vegetation the Snowsnufflers feed upon.
So, the Snowsnufflers have sniffed their way
into an enviable spot on the food-web.
But there’s more than one way to survive
on a planet of ice.
Horned Chillmanders are scaly creatures that
aren’t as well insulated from the cold,
and aren’t as proficient at sniffing out
food.
Instead, they have a different strategy to
confront the low temperatures — hibernation.
On Earth, numerous animals hibernate during
winter months, slowing their metabolic rate
to conserve energy — only to emerge again
when food is more abundant.
On planet Boreas, however, temperatures drop
without warning year-round — which is why
the Chillmanders are capable of slowing their
metabolic rate multiple times per year.
These lethargic lifeforms spend most of their
time basking in the sun, expending precious
little energy even when not hibernating.
It’s a lifestyle I’m a bit jealous of,
even if it’s not the most exciting.
Yet where there are herbivores — particularly
abundant, slow-moving ones — there are invariably
carnivores.
Lumbermaws are tall, somewhat awkward looking
predators that spend most of their time reared
up on their hind legs to intimidate rivals
and survey the landscape.
While they are the dominant predators of this
region, Lumbermaws aren’t particularly aggressive.
Like many species of bears, they are hypocarnivorous,
meaning their diet consists mostly of fungi,
berries, and other plant materials rather
than meat.
After all, on a planet as harsh as Boreas,
being picky just isn’t practical.
I’m not entirely certain if they’d like
the taste of me, so I’ll give them some
personal space.
Planet Boreas is an extreme and fascinating
world, but the time has come to continue our
voyage…
Our next galactic destination is Planet Nereus,
home to an incredible planetwide ocean.
Entering the atmosphere, I find that only
a few small islands break up the endless expanse
of water.
Most life on Planet Nereus is likely waiting
under the waves.
Yet touching down on one of the larger islands,
I find some intrepid species have come ashore.
At the water’s edge, I spot a coastal Shellswimmer.
Amphibious herbivores, Shellswimmers feed
off marine plants that grow in the shallows
just beyond the shore.
It’s a lifestyle similar to the Marine Iguanas
of the Galápagos Islands, which likewise
spend most of their lifespan in the intertidal
zone.
On Planet Nereus, even land-dwellers are tied
to the sea.
Elsewhere on the island, the bizarre Glowhorns
feed on coastal swamp-grass.
In appearance and behavior, Glowhorns are
convergent with hoofed ruminant mammals like
deer.
Yet when night falls, these lifeforms reveal
a side that is all their own.
Bioluminescent display structures on their
back light up, creating a dazzling display
that helps the Glowhorns find potential mates
in the darkness.
It’s a mesmerizing spectacle to see in person.
Yet the light of Glowhorns can attract more
than potential mates.
It can also attract predators.
And on the island coast, no predator is more
dangerous than the Terrorbeak.
These t-rex-like creatures are huge, towering
over all other land animals on these islands.
It might seem surprising to see large creatures
in an isolated ecosystem, yet this is actually
an example of Island Gigantism.
A trend that exists on Earth as well in species
like Komodo Dragons, Island Gigantism is a
biological phenomenon in which a species on
an island increases dramatically in size.
For the Terrorbeaks, their massive bulk allows
them to feed on any species they wish…
Yet land animals make up only a small percentage
of life on Nereus.
Diving under the waves, I find a much denser
ecosystem awaits.
The first lifeforms I spot are the inquisitive,
tentacled Cephalophores, that move in sporadic
patterns in accordance to the ocean currents.
Cephalophores travel in groups, perhaps for
protection, or perhaps because they just like
the company.
Their soft bodies and manipulatory tentacles
resemble those of an octopus — and like
octopuses, they’re quite intelligent.
Exactly how intelligent is difficult to measure,
but they show an acute sense of curiosity,
circling around me as I swim by.
I wonder if perhaps the Cephalophores feel
they are studying me.
The bulk of underwater species within the
planet-wide ocean are fast moving, fish-like
lifeforms we’ll call Silverfins.
They gather in schools that number in the
thousands, much like the true fish of our
oceans.
And with such high numbers, Silverfins are
an appealing food source for aquatic predators.
And one such predator is lurking below.
This silent, streamlined hunter is a Saltwater
Reefstalker.
The premier hunter of this global ocean, Reefstalkers
are significantly faster than their preferred
prey — using their muscular tail to propel
themselves through the water.
Their torpedo-like body plan mirrors that
of most sharks, as does their killer appetite.
In these bountiful waters, every day is a
feast.
Yet fortunately, like Earth sharks, this Reefstalker
ultimately isn’t that interested in taking
a bite out of me.
All the same, I’d feel safer with some extra
protection.
To explore the deepest region of this global
ocean, I’m traveling in an aquatic exocraft
called a Nautilon.
And at the bottom of the largest trench of
Planet Nereus, something mysterious is waiting.
A bright light emanates from the eye of a
strange organism growing from a wall.
Exiting my submarine, I move in closer, only
to be caught in a hypnotic vortex of light.
It takes all my strength to break away.
That was an Abyssal Horror, a lifeform that
calls to prey with a bioluminescent lure,
much like an Earth angler fish.
I suddenly feel that I have seen enough of
planet Nereus…
Racing along through the stars, I find my
ship is low on fuel.
Fortunately, I know just the place to get
some more.
This strange geometric construction is a space
station — a common sight in this part of
the cosmos.
They function almost like intergalactic truck
stops, and are open to all kinds of space-faring
life.
As our ship enters the space station through
the main aperture, the automatic guidance
system takes over, and we’re ushered towards
the first available landing pad.
After so much time exploring the cosmic wilds,
it’s a strange sensation to return to an
artificial environment.
Yet we need fuel to continue our expedition,
so we might as well relax.
This station is run by the diminutive Gek
— one of the primary sentient species in
this region of space.
They’re organized and rather pragmatic beings,
more interested in practical matters than
conversation.
While I’d like to know more about the specifics
of their biology, I’ve yet to meet a Gek
comfortable with discussing that topic, so
I won’t press it.
All sorts of different species pass through
this particular station.
Some, like the mysterious Korvax, appear to
be entirely artificial.
How these inorganic lifeforms function is
of particular interest, but like the Gek,
they aren’t keen on sharing secrets.
Still, just being in the presence of other
intelligent lifeforms — some of which are
likely explorers themselves — is a special
privilege.
But with the ship refueled, the time is right
to return to our voyage…
The second to last planet we’ll be visiting
is the most extreme so far.
Planet Helios orbits extremely close to its
star — making it a world of blistering temperatures.
Entering the atmosphere, a sun-scorched landscape
of ash and smoke awaits.
Aside from the sun’s rays, endless geothermal
activity means Planet Helios is a domain of
fire.
Only a few barren plants are able to take
root in this infernal biosphere.
I don’t expect to find much life here…
But life is nothing if not stubborn.
A few persistent organisms have risen to the
challenge.
The most tenacious creatures we’ll call
Igneobeasts, lifeforms with a curious defense
against the heat.
Like the Sea Pangolins of the Indian Ocean,
they incorporate mineral-sulfides into their
hide like a kind of fire-resistant second-skin
— allowing Igneobeasts to survive in this
volcanic wasteland.
Igneobeasts are also excellent tunnellers,
allowing them to dig for edible roots and
underground aquifers.
It’s an extreme life — but a life all
the same.
And speaking of extreme...
That was a Heliostrider, a titanic lifeform
with a body-plan unlike any organism I’ve
ever come across.
Their alarming height means that Heliostriders
pay little mind to anything on this planet’s
surface.
Like Igneobeasts, these omnivores feed primarily
on buried plant matter, sticking their heads
underground to get a meal.
It’s a somewhat awkward behavior that calls
to mind how ostriches look when burying their
eggs.
Like most lifeforms on planet Helios, the
skin of the Heliostrider seems highly resistant
to the merciless solar radiation.
In fact, the Heliostriders are practically
thriving.
But not all creatures on planet Helios are
quite so fortunate.
Cragspines are midsized scavengers that struggle
to find sustenance in this barren environment.
At a glance, they resemble the savanna foxes
of our planet, although the niche they occupy
is less enviable.
Cragspines live short, sweaty lives under
the uncaring sun, rarely getting enough food
to stave off hunger.
A harsh existence for a harsh world.
Planet Helios has shown us the incredible
tenacity of life.
But now let’s head to our final planet...
At the end of our journey through the stars,
the massive, mysterious planet Erebus awaits.
From our current position, it’s impossible
to tell what the surface looks like.
Entering the atmosphere and flying below the
clouds, I discover a hidden paradise is waiting.
With a temperate climate and abundant vegetation,
Planet Erebus is a place where evolution is
free to experiment like never before.
And here is one such experiment now.
My goodness.
This is a, well, it’s difficult to think
of a name.
I’ll call them…
George.
The Georges appear to be herbivores, with
mouths located on the underside of their bodies.
To feed, Georges simply move across the rich
carpet of vegetation that covers the planet,
essentially functioning like living lawnmowers.
Their system of locomotion is comparable to
terrestrial snails — which slowly propel
themselves using waves of muscular contractions.
Dozens of primitive eyes cover the front end
of the Georges, which might seem like overkill.
Yet certain types of scallops on our own planet
are known to have an even higher total eye-count.
It’s easy to dismiss the Georges as some
sort of biological misadventure.
Yet all forms of life, no matter how bizarre,
are their own sort of miracle.
In the skies above Planet Erebus, something
remarkable is passing overhead.
These are Areoderms, a remarkable form of
floating life.
They’re held aloft by some kind of internal
gas-bladder.
Their trunks aren’t quite as impressive
as those of an elephant, and are perhaps more
analogous to the short prehensile noses of
Tapirs.
Yet Areoderms can feed on the tops of trees,
as their buoyant bodies mean nothing is out
of reach...
For the last leg of my journey across Planet
Erebus, I’ll be using a special research
vehicle.
This exocraft is called a Minotaur — a robust
mechanical walker that allows me to travel
further and stay safer.
And it seems the extra precautions weren’t
a mistake.
A horrifying mass of tentacles burst from
the ground, grasping at the air close to me.
This subterranean terror cannot be seen in
full, so I’ll simply call them Nightmares.
Without being able to see the rest of these
lifeforms, it is impossible to determine their
exact biology — but they seem to be ambush
predators that burrow under their targets
and attack from below.
Even a paradise like Erebus can be a dangerous
place to linger...
Yet with the night, a deep calm settles over
this normally restless planet.
It is a bittersweet feeling to know our voyage
is complete, but the day has come to head
home…
Yet of course, No Man’s Sky is a game without
an end.
Beyond each horizon is another one — each
planet is just a fleeting waypoint in a voyage
without a destination.
There’s a certain melancholy the game can
evoke, as the sheer size of the universe creeps
into one’s mind.
No matter how long you spend in this universe,
on a cosmic scale, there is only much a single
entity can do and see.
I think the team behind this project have
done an admirable job expanding this procedural
universe.
And I’m excited to know what comes next.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support by liking, subscribing, and hitting
the notification icon to stay up to date on
all things Curious.
See you in the next video.